Ah
ah now the paper I write down here is the
protest at the end I remember but there are a lot of them
like this * small bird in order  It's a
laptop, someone said it
was cool in the Korean economy, and it's cinematic. Oh, okay, uh, I'm talking
about the last comment, but I'm a little culturally
confirmed.  There are 3 apps really
really ah this time it's just taengtang ah ah ah I haven't seen it yet
[laughs] The
phone is really standing like that Director Christo Controversy Hwangto-sama I love you so much
4 so 3 It's like the content It
's a code Disney and ah What did you drink there before?  1st 4
in that ring I'll solve my thoughts like a person like Calvin in the
original term please ask for the title woman and
this
1 4 really really good movie is thick wow that's it again
5 4
lemon six last time u sooooo fact day
ah  Have a perfect day Give me why when do I get it
Yes Eyebrows are closed Arthur is
playing uh lately Yes uh I asked about uh and when he made it just
perfect
Ah when I feel the corner top Ah today is perfect flow He said that there is a lot of difference  That
woman charge wife more o oh listen only o hyung and now what yes really this is the
earth now
seriously and recommends
me  Rado Comments Da Kurt Invitation Event Ha You Do Me
No I wrote it first to recommend it When this pride was put in and made ok
Flower a is also expressed, but I
think people are perfect Uh yeah I have a little more mood.
Ah ah ah
[Music]
Uh